DEAF, DUMB, AND BLIND ON THE
ISSUES THAT MATTER MOST.
JOINING ME NOW GINGRICH, THE
RULES NEVER i PLIE TO THEM,
THEY NEVER HAVE TO LIVE WITH A
CARNAGE AND THE RUIN THAT THEIR
POLICIES CREATE BECAUSE THEY
KIND OF FLOAT ABOVE IT.
BUT THEY WERE CAUGHT HERE,
WEREN'T THEY?
>> THEY WERE CAUGHT.
FRANKLY, MY FAVORITE WASN'T ON
THE ISLAND, ALTHOUGH I DO THINK
WITH BARACK OBAMA, I THINK 29
ACRE ESTATE HE COULD EASILY HAVE
HOSTED EVERYBODY THERE; HAD A
NICE PECK NIC, ALLOWED THEM TO
CAMP OUT.
BUT THE ONE I LIKE EVEN MORE WAS
THE TWO BUS LOADS ARRIVING AT
COMMA LAW HARRIS' VICE PRESIDENT
RESIDENCE JUST SHORTLY AFTER SHE
ANNOUNCED ON NBC NEWS THAT THE
BORDER IS SECURE.
YOU KNOW, THE IRONY.
OF HOW TOTALLY DISHONEST SHE IS
AND THE FACT THAT GOVERNOR ABBOT
DID A GREAT JOB BETWEEN GOVERNOR
ABBOT AND GOVERNOR DE SANTIS, I
FEEL LIKE REPUBLICANS ARE BACK
ON OFFENSE, AND ARE FINDING A
WAY TO BREAKTHROUGH THE MEDIA
BECAUSE THIS WAS SO VIVID IN
BOTH PLACES THAT ACTUALLY THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA FOUND
THEMSELVES HAVE BEEN HAVING TO
COVER.
>> I FINALLY REPUBLICANS ARE
PRODUCING EVENTS RATHER THAN
JUST TALKING AT ME PEOPLE.
RELEASING STATEMENTS OR
MULTIPART PLANS, THAT'S FINE.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG THAT.
WHEN YOU CREATE EVENT THAT ARE
NEWSWORTHY THEY HAVE TO COVER
THEM AND THEN ALL OF A SUD B,
YOU SEE SPLIT SCREENS WHERE WITH
THE TRUTH HAPPENING ON ONE SIDE
AND THEN A BUNCH OF ANGRY
LIBERALS ON THE OTHER.
NEWT, I NEED TO PLAY SOMETHING.
THIS WAS FROM BIDEN LAST NIGHT,
WHERE I THINK IF YOU LISTEN
CLOSELY HE BASICALLY GAVE UP THE
GAME
.
>> HISTORIC AMERICAN RES KAI
PLAN HELPS TO SAFELY REOPEN OUR
SCHOOLS AN ABSOLUTE NECESSITY,
INCLUDING 28 PERCENT OF PUBLIC
SCHOOL STUDENTS WHO ARE LATINO.
28 PERCENT.
MAKE SHARE THEY HAVE EVERY
OPPORTUNITY THEY HAVE.
NOT A JOKE.
>> AS SOMEONE WHO HAPPENS TO
LOVE HISPANIC AMERICANS AS
MYSELF, MY DAUGHTER'S FROM
GUATEMALA, THEY GET UPSET WHEN
YOU SAY THERE'S DEMOGRAPHIC
CHANGES GOING ON, PEOPLE DON'T
LIKE THAT LANGUAGE, IT'S FRAUGHT
WITH ALL SORTS OF THINGS.
BUT HE'S KIND OF IN A
WARIERENNING THAT IN THAT
COMMENT.
>> WELL, YES, YOU KNOW, THE
AMAZING THING IS BECAUSE MOST
LATINO FAMILIES BELIEVE IN THE
WORK ETHIC, BECAUSE THEY CARE
ABOUT TAKE-HOME PAY, BECAUSE
THEY'RE AWARE OF THE COST OF
LIVING CRISIS WE'RE LIVING
THROUGH, AND BECAUSE THEY HAVE
CORE VALUES THAT MAKE THEM
REALLY ANGRY ABOUT A LOT OF THE
LEFT WING WOKE IDEAS, YOU'RE
SEEING A LARGER AND LARGER
NUMBER OF LATINO AMERICANS VOTE
REPUBLICAN.
SO, I THINK WHATEVER THE
DEMOCRATS THEORY WAS, THEIR
TOTAL FAILURE TO DELIVER THE
FACT THAT IT JUST ISIBILITY
WORKING, IS COSTING THEM VOTES
IN EVERY COMMUNITY AFRICAN
AMERICAN, LATINO AMERICAN, ASIAN
AMERICAN, AS WELL AS TRADITIONAL
WHITE AMERICANS, BECAUSE YOU
LOOK AROUND.
YOU GO TO THE GROCERY STORE, YOU
LOOK AT THE PRICE OF CHEERIOS,
AND YOU KNOW IT JUST
ISN'TWORKING.
I THINK THAT THE GREAT PROBLEM
AND THAT WHY I STILL BELIEVE
THERE'S GOING TO BE AN AMAZINGLY
BIG REPUBLICAN VICTOR THIS FALL.
>> YEAH, I THINK THE HISPANIC,
AGAIN, USING THEIR FRAUGHT
LANGUAGE, THEY'RE ACTUALLY GOING
TO REPLACE THE DEMOCRATS BECAUSE
THEY'RE VOTING REPUBLICAN.
I DON'T THINK THEY KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE, THEY'RE KIND OF MIXED
UP INIA HO THEY'RE TRYING TO
ANALYZE THIS AS USUAL.
TODAY ON MS NBC NEWS THEY WERE
DISCUSSING ONE OF THE SO-CALLED
SOLUTIONS THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS LOOKING AT
HERE.
WATCH.
>> THERE ARE DHS OFFICIAL WHOSE
ARE GOING TO MEETINGS CALLED AT
THE WHITE HOUSE PRETTY REGULARLY
NU WHERE THEY'RE LOOKING AT
THESE NUMBERS THAT ARE GOING UP,
COMING P WITH SOLUTIONS, SOME OF
THEM INCLUDE BUSING MIGRANTS
FROM THE BORDER INTO THE
INTERIOR, BUT NOT IN A WAY WHERE
YOU'RE SURPRISE THE COMMUNITY
LIKE THIS IN MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
>> IT'S BAD WHEN THEY GO TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD BECAUSE IT
AFFECTS THE ELITES AND THE
ELITES LIKE TO TALK ABOUT CARING
ABOUT IMMIGRANTS BUT IN THE END
THEY JUST WANT TO DEPORT THEM,
VOTE THEM AT ISLAND.
>> WELL, WHAT SHE JUST SAID IS A
TOTAL LIE.  THEY HAVE BEEN
FLYING PEOPLE AROUND, SENDING
THEM AROUND BY TRAIN, AND
THOUGHT TELLING LOCAL
AUTHORITIES.
THEY'VE BEEN LANDING AT NIGHT IN
PLACES LIKE WESTCHESTER.
THE FACT IS THAT YOU'VE ALL 2
MILLION PEOPLE CROSS THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY UNDER JOE BIDEN, AND
THEY DIDN'T ALL STAY IN SOUTH
TEXAS.
THEY'RE ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
AND IN FACT, WHAT'S BOTHERING I
THINK THE DEMOCRATS IS THAT YOU
NOW HAVE A COUPLE OF GOVERNOR
WHOSE ARE MAKING SURE THE PUBLIC
UNDERSTANDS WHAT IS ACTUALLY
BEEN GOING ON ANYWAY.
AND REMEMBER, THIS ISN'T THE MID
OF A CRIME EPIDEMIC ON A SCALE
WE HAVIVE SEEN, NOT EVEN EN THE
70S.  PHILIP D'AMATO DEVIL YOU
THIS YEAR WILL HAVE THE HIGHEST
MURDER HIS OR, ATLANTA NOW HAS A
HIGHER PER CAPITA MURDER RATE
THAN CHICAGO.
AND OF COURSE IN CHICAGO, A HUGE
CRIME PROBLEM, THE PEOPLE IN THE
DEMOCRATS AND STATE LEGISLATURE
JUST VOTED TO END BAIL FOR CASH
CRIMINALS BACK ON THE STREET IN
A WAY THAT YOU IS TO WONDER ARE
THESE PEOPLE JUST CRAZY BECAUSE
THERE'SER IF ES.
NOT JUST POLITICAL.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT BEING A
RADICAL LEFTEST, THIS IS ABOUT
BEING NUTSEM.
>> YEAH, THEY'RE DRIVING
BUSINESSES OUT OF CHICAGO TOO AS
WE KNOW WITH MCDONALD'S RAISING
THE RED FLAG.
FINALLY MBC NEWS IS REPORTING
THAT BIDEN AIDS ARE QUIETLY
ASSEMBLING A 2024 CAMPAIGN AS
THEY AWAIT FINAL DECISIONS ON
HIS POLITICAL FUTURE.
NEWT, THEY'RE TRYING TO AVOID
THE LAME DUCK LABEL BUT BIDEN
2024 BUMPER STICKERS?
ARE THEY READY TO BE PLASTERED
ALL OVER CARS ACROSS AMERICA?
>> LISTEN, IF I WERE THE
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES I WOULD BE
PESTERING BIDEN 2024 STICKERS AS
FAST AS I CAN GET THEM.
I THINK EVERY CANDIDATE RUNNING
ON THE DEMOCRATIC TICKET IS A
BIDEN WORN OUT TEXT, A BIDEN
FETTERMAN TICKET, IT'S A BIDEN
MARK KELLY TICKET.
LET'S ALL LET'S SEE HOW MANY OF
THEM WANT TO ACTUALLY TRY TO
DEFEND BIDEN.
AS I SAID A MINUTE AGO, YOU HAVE
A HUGE PROBLEM IN THE PRICE OF
FOOD, THE PRICE OF GASOLINE.
WHEN HEATING OIL PRICES GO UP IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE IN OCTOBER, I WANT
TO SEE HOW SENATOR HASSAN
ANSWERS THAT.
I THINK THE BIDEN YOU'RE PAIGE
STAFF IF YOU'RE HANGING ROUND,
WHY NOT INVENT A BIDEN 2024
BUMPER STICKER.
IT COULD HAVE A KIND OF FROWNY
FACE BECAUSE THAT'S HOW THE
COUNTRY WILL REACT